-She's Oscar-nominated
for her movie
"Promising Young Woman,"
and she's hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend
with musical guest Kid Cudi.
Please welcome Carey Mulligan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Come on!
That's what I'm talking about!
Great to see you.
-Hi.
-Not too sha--
Oh, my. Standing O!
Come on. Welcome.
Please have a seat.
-Oh, come on.
-Carey, thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-Now we're going to face off
in a game called "Box of Lies."
-[ Exhales slowly ]
-♪ Box of Lies, box of Lies ♪
♪ Box of Lies, box of Lies ♪
♪ Box of Lies ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
Okay, on your turn, you pick
a box, take out the object,
and describe it
to your opponent.
Then they have to guess
if you're lying
or telling the truth.
We're going to play
three rounds.
I don't want to look at you
because I think
maybe you're already
playing the game.
Carey, you pick the first box.
-I go first? Okay.
-Yeah.
-This one!
-Ooh, it's heavy! Okay.
All right. Oof.
-Okay. It did feel --
It did sound heavy.
So that's the first clue.
-Oh, no.
-Yep. Okay.
I think I got this one.
[ Laughter ]
Carey, when you're ready.
You can tell me.
What is in your box?
-It's another box.
And it's got sort of
pink spaghetti
with glitter
and, like, tiny little trolls
all around in a circle
like they're at
some sort of meeting.
[ Laughter ]
-So in your box is another box.
-Yeah.
-Okay. And in that box...
-...there's a spaghetti
in the middle
and then trolls standing
around it like it's a ritual.
-Like a ritual thing.
-A ritual, yeah.
-Yeah.
-And they're --
The dolls are touching hands?
-They're not touching hands.
They're socially distanced,
but they're --
[ Laughter ]
-They're
socially distant trolls.
-They're --
It's sort of like they're at --
Yeah, they're at a big meeting.
And there's, like,
little baby ones, big ones,
and all their hair is like this.
-Classic trolls. Yeah.
-Classic troll. Yeah.
-That would be weird. Why would
you have to describe their hair?
That's interesting, right?
-I don't know
why I would have to.
-Yeah. Because maybe
it's not real maybe.
-Aw.
-Aw. Too bad.
Maybe you're just making
this whole thing up.
Trolls, spaghetti.
Another box in the box.
You described that
they have hair, crazy hair.
Yeah. Oh, really?
Trolls have crazy hair?
Wow. Thanks for the description.
I didn't know what that meant.
[ Laughter ]
Or are you just
being so obvious...
-So specific.
-...that I'm spinning myself up?
-Yeah.
-You know?
-Mm-hmm.
-[ Chuckles ]
Carey Mulligan.
-Yeah.
-You tell the truth.
-I lied!
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ] Unbelievable!
What is it? Let me see it.
-Look. It's a hat
full of bolognese.
-How did you do that?
You are unb--
Of course, you were
going to be great at this.
Are you kidding me?
You are a fantastic actor.
Oh, my gosh. I honestly --
You are so good!
-Thank you!
-All right. Now it is
my turn to pick a box.
Which number, everyone?
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
It's either three or five.
Now you're just --
Now you're just grunting.
[ Imitates shouting ]
Yeah. "Ehh" is nothing.
Ehh? Four?
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
[ Exhales heavily ]
[ Grunting ]
[ Thud ]
-All right.
-Wow. That was heavy.
-Yeah.
-[ Exhales shakily ]
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-All right.
[British accent] All right.
Hello! Hello!
♪♪
-What's in the box?
-[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
There's a connection to you.
-Okay.
-It's a classic.
It's a tiny tennis racket
holding a classic novel,
"The Great Gatsby."
-A tennis racket
is holding a novel?
-It's a tiny -- It's more
of a stand, a book stand.
Holding a novel.
The novel is "The Great Gatsby."
But it's "The Great Tatsby."
[ Laughter ]
And it's Leo
giving you a tattoo.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Uh-huh.
I don't understand why you said
it was a tennis racket.
What is it that? I don't --
-A tennis racket
is holding the book up.
-A tenn-- Does
the tennis racket have arms?
Like, is it a cartoon?
-It's a tiny tennis --
It's a book holder.
It's like a --
-I've never seen
a book-holding tennis racket.
-It's a novelty.
It's a tennis racket
on its side,
and the book
is in the middle of the racket.
-Okay.
-Like a bookshelf thing.
Like, have you ever seen
two hands on the end
of a book shelf?
Like it's novelty.
-Yeah, but that's not -- Okay.
Is this an American thing?
-[ Laughs ] Sure.
-Okay.
-Sure it is.
It's an old-timey
wooden tennis racket.
-And it's holding a book?
So, what --
Is the book a picture of us?
-It's a picture of you.
Leo is giving you a tattoo.
"The Great Tatsby"
is what it says.
-"The Great Tatsby." Okay.
-Yeah.
-Any other details
you want to -- Nothing else?
-You're getting a barbed wire --
Barbed-wire tattoo on your arm.
-That's what the tattoo is of?
-That's correct.
-Okay.
-And you're not enjoying it.
-Can I tell you what I think?
-Yeah, I would love to hear it.
I can't wait.
-I think you're lying.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
Oh, wow!
-Chess pizza.
-That's great.
-Was it the aroma of pizza?
-Is it an actual pizza?
-Yes.
-Oh, wow. It is.
That's not far off
my troll ritual.
-Oh. Actually --
Weirdly. you're right.
Wow. It's like you ca--
This is the trickiest game
of "Box of Lies" we ever played.
You're actually
creating the truth.
No one's ever done that.
-No? Okay.
-Gosh. You're a mastermind.
All right. Here we go.
So it's a close game.
But you know what?
This last round
is worth 10,000 points.
-Oh, my gosh.
-So whoever wins this round
is the champion.
Now, Carey, you're up.
Please choose a box.
-Okay.
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-[ Jimmy grunting ]
[ Laughs ]
-Unnnnnhh!
-Nice acting job. Oh, my gosh.
So I already know it's light.
-All right.
-Yep.
-No problem, no problem.
Number two. The deuce!
That's what they call it.
♪♪
Okay, and the wheels
are spinning.
I can already see.
She's choosing.
-This is actually "SNL"-themed.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. A lot of themes
going tonight.
-It's -- Well, it's a themed --
It's a themed thing.
It's a mug, a T-shirt,
and, like, a beach towel
of some description.
From Tracy Morgan?
So it's like a --
-What you just pulled out
of that box was a mug,
a T-shirt, and beach towel?
-Yeah, but, like, wrapped up.
Wrapped up.
-How wrapped
is that beach towel?
Is this, like, an American --
a British thing?
-No, it has like --
-Like a tiny beach towel?
-Yeah, it's like for a baby.
-[ Laughs ] That's
a good business, by the way.
Baby beach towel.
-Baby beach towels.
-So you're saying it is a mug.
-It's a mug, it's a beach towel,
and it's a --
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, no. Oh, no!
It's sinking fast!
-Or am I just brilliant?
-No.
That already happened
the first round.
You were brilliant
in the first round.
-Yeah.
-This one, I think this one --
You came in with this one.
-Yeah.
-This is your safety lie.
-And what happened was,
you kind of freaked out
and you go,
"Am I going to tell the truth
and just say what it is?
That would really get
Jimmy going.
Or do I make up a whole lie?"
Your pre-made lie
that you probably talked
to your publicist about before.
You go, "Saturday Night Live,"
Tracy Morgan.
That will make Jimmy guess that.
And you think I'm that easy
to put the lock in
and flip the switch
and open my -- err -- door,
hop into the brain, and go...
[British accent]
..."Good day, love!"
[Normal voice] Try again.
You picked the wrong day.
What I'm trying to say
is, Carey Mulligan...
you lie!
-Unh!
-Yes!
♪♪
[ Laughs ] That's not bad!
[ Laughs ]
That actually is not bad.
You know how I kind of knew?
-Yeah.
-'Cause you kind of smiled
a little bit when you saw it.
-I know, I know.
But I tried so hard not to.
-I know.
But your dimples gave you away!
There is Carey Mulligan,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Clearly better at this
than I am.